So we'll begin by recapping what the Unreal Engine building blocks are.
Unreal offers many established classes that provide core functionality out of the box,
and going through these will help put the rest of this talk into a better perspective.
We'll only briefly touch on these, as I'd highly recommend that you watch our
previous talk, that being an introduction to Unreal Engine 4 for programmers, into
which we do a deeper dive into these topics.
As mentioned previously, UObject is the base class for all UE4 types, including all
assets inside the content browser.
They have no physical representation in the world, and they have no built-in tick
functionality. As they've got no concept of the world, they have no ability to
update the frame. They must be given an outer.
This is the object that this object resides in.
If one is not given an outer, it's put inside the transient package, which is the
topmost package used for storing temporary objects, which should not be saved.
Objects can support networking, but they do not come with it set about the box.
If networking is required, perhaps reconsider whether or not UObject is the
right solution for your current technical requirement.
As an example of a UObject, we have the UExplosionData asset, which is used
to define properties regarding an explosion.
Actor extends directly off of UObject, and is usually accompanied by a scene
component as its route, giving it a physical representation in the scene.
For example, consider an exploding barrel.
This would be an actor, consisting of smaller discrete pieces of functionality,
and a physical representation through some flavor of mesh.
Actors do have networking support by default, giving us access to RPCs like we
discussed earlier, as well as standard variable replication.
They're exceptionally well suited to a component-based architecture,
as opposed to a giant monolithic class.
So at this time, consider the following.
If my current technical design requires either networking or ticking,
go with actors and components.
If you don't require either, consider using the UObject.
Actor components allow us to roll functionality into a single class.
They require an actor to exist, because they cannot simply exist in the world.
They're designed to be part of an actor.
And they're excellent when used in conjunction with Blueprint to expose their parameters
to design with sensible U-property use.
So as an example, we can add an explosion component to our exploding barrel actor,
and keep the actor class completely unpolluted.
If another actor in our game requires some kind of explosion functionality,
we can simply add the component to that class as well,
without having to duplicate anything.
We can also add U-properties to the explosion component,
to allow design to plug in an explosion data asset in as a field,
letting them balance and tweak the functionality separately.
Actor components are not particularly ideal for networked functionality,
as dormancy can only be set on an actor level, as opposed to a component level.
A dormant actor will send all of its components dormant as well,
so we may end up with erroneous or unacceptable behavior as the project grows.
A scene component extends off of actor component,
with the benefit of providing a physical representation in the scene.
They can be attached to other scene components as well as bones and sockets,
and they can also be used to detect collisions and overlaps.
It's the scene component that gives a base actor its physical representation in the scene.
An actor itself has got no intrinsic transform,
but it does have a root component,
which is a simple scene component giving us our scene representation.
With the recap over, let's take a look at the player.
What classes and concepts do we need to be familiar with
in order to get a player up and running?
The Pawn offers the entry point for actors that can be possessed by either a player or the AI.
By default, the Pawn class gives a physical representation in the scene,
but it's otherwise a plain canvas for us to build from.
Pawns have a one-to-one relationship with controllers,
meaning each Pawn can only have one controller,
and each controller can only control one Pawn.
It's important to note that the Pawn is not assumed to be humanoid,
and it does not provide any default movement,
skeletal mesh, or collision components.
It only provides a default scene component,
that being its root component.
The Pawn extends off of the actor class,
and as such has access to some of its core functionality,
such as its location and rotation manipulation.
In Blueprints, we can quite easily add movement to our Pawns
using the set actor location function like we just discussed.
This function allows us to either teleport the Pawn from its current location,
or we can perform what we call a sweeping move.
The sweeping move essentially slides the Pawn from point A to point B,
stopping as soon as they collide with any geometry.
Pawns spawned during gameplay are not automatically possessed by a controller.
However, we do have some options exposed out,
so we can have some semblance of control.
So let's take a look at those in the editor.
So whilst Pawn gives us a base for all controllable actors,
the default Pawn and spectator Pawns build on top of that
to provide us some out-of-the-box functionality.
The default Pawn provides us with the following components.
We're gonna get a default Pawn movement component,
a spherical collision component, and a mesh component.
It also provides built-in functionality
to add default movement bindings, which are on by default,
cutting out the need
for any manual adding of movement logic to your Pawn,
whether that be native or Blueprint.
The movement that it offers is as follows.
We get forwards, backwards, left, right, and jump.
The default Pawn movement component
offers a no-gravity, flying-style movement
as the Pawn is not assumed to be humanoid.
The default Pawn movement component
exposes controls over maximum speed,
acceleration, and deceleration to Blueprint.
The spectator Pawn, on the other hand,
is a subclass of default Pawn
and provides us with a simple framework
ideal for spectating functionality.
Like default Pawn, it offers much the same components,
but it does away with a mesh component,
as spectators typically don't have a mesh.
The spectator Pawn does, however,
provide its own movement component,
that being the spectator Pawn movement component.
And it's largely the same
as the default Pawn's movement component,
with added functionality of handling
or ignoring time dilation as necessary.
A character is a humanoid-style Pawn,
and it is assumed to be vertically orientated.
The character brings with it its own movement component,
which offers a greater range of movement
than the Pawn movement component,
allowing characters to walk, run, jump, fly, fall,
and swim through the world.
The character movement component is heavily networked,
making it the perfect type to use
when thinking about un-networked games.
The character is the first class along the Pawn hierarchy
to provide specific functions for crouching and jumping,
as well as overriding several variables and functions
to specifically facilitate replication
inside the character movement component.
Unlike Pawns, the character comes
with a skeletal mesh component,
which enables us to make use of animations.
The native skeletal mesh provided by the character
is also the main skeletal mesh
associated with the character,
but more skeletal meshes can be added
to the character as we see fit.
The character also offers some animation functionality,
such as allowing us to play and stop animation montages,
both in native and in blueprint.
It also provides a capsule collision component
straight out of the box.
As mentioned previously,
the character is assumed to be vertically orientated,
and this is due to the functionality provided
by the capsule collision component,
which in order to calculate complicated geometries
make this assumption.
The character movement component is a component
specially created to be paired with a character.
It provides encapsulated movement systems
for humanoid characters,
which are assumed to be vertically orientated.
It handles movements such as walking, running, swimming,
falling, or flying,
and it's built with networking in mind
with the aforementioned movement modes
built to replicate straight out of the box.
As mentioned before,
it is created to be paired with the character in mind,
as the character class overrides variables and functions
that facilitate the networking side
of the movement component.
Custom movement modes can be created
and can be handled
by the character movement component directly,
giving the developer complete control
over how their custom movement mode
is handled when it comes
to updating the character's position,
as each movement mode handles its own movement logic.
For example, if the movement mode is move walking,
then it will call the fizz walking function.
The character movement component isn't blueprintable,
so for handling custom movement modes
outside of native implementations,
it's usually recommended
to handle it inside the character blueprint directly
using the update custom movement blueprint event
that's fired when a custom movement mode is processed.
So now that we know what a pawn and character is,
we naturally have to discuss controllers.
Controllers are a non-physical actor
that possess pawns or a pawn derived class.
This is done through the possess and unpossess functions,
both of which are available in native and blueprint.
The base class for controllers is the AController class,
and this class defines some of the core functionality
of a controller,
and also make use of the class specifies abstract
and non-placeable.
The form of these specifies works as you'd expect,
it marks the class as abstract
and therefore cannot be instantiated directly,
while the latter marks the class
so that it cannot be clicked and dragged into the editor.
As discussed previously,
they have a one-to-one relationship with a pawn,
and this is usually desired by most game types,
but they may not meet all requirements
where possession of multiple pawns may be desired.
Controllers also receive many notifications of events
that occur for the pawn,
and this gives developers the opportunity
to implement functionality for the given event
and supersede the behaviour that the pawn may trigger.
It's also possible to make the controller tick
before the controlled pawn,
which can be used to minimise latency
between input processing and the pawn's movement,
an important thing when it comes to player controllers.
Controllers do not expose transform functions
to derived classes in native.
Controllers attach themselves to their pawn
when they possess and detach when they unpossess.
So what types of controller
does Unreal give us out of the box?
Well, as the title suggests,
Unreal gives us the player controller and the AI controller.
Player controllers represent the human player's will.
Player controllers are flexible
and a key tool for developers
when considering the gameplay loops of their games.
For instance, they can be used
to handle the input notifications rather than the pawn.
It's important to consider what functionality
should be placed in the player controller over the pawn.
So for example, if you have a game
in which the player can swap around many characters,
then it would make sense to implement
the input handling within the controller,
as the controller can simply relay those commands
onto the currently controlled pawn.
The player controller, unlike the pawn,
persists as only one is created for that player
when they're loaded into the map,
whereas pawns are transient.
If your game has a gameplay loop
in which the player's character dies and respawns,
Unreal will destroy the current pawn upon death
and a new one will be assigned to the player
when respawning, but importantly,
it will be controlled
by the player's existing player controller.
AI controllers, on the other hand,
are exactly as you'd expect.
They're the simulated will of an AI agent.